>> So far in this lesson we've discussed six different
professions that use genetic information for their day to day lives.
>> But we've only scratched the surface, there
are a ton of other fields that use genetic
information; for example, forensic scientists and police departments use
it a lot. Even drug researchers like pharmaceutical companies.
>> And even science illustrators or science journalists need to have a firm
understanding of science and genetics. To write
and represent this information to the public.
>> Pretty much any clinical practitioner
would need to know something about genetics.
>> Now, because we don't have the time to
cover all these other different kinds of jobs as
well in this lesson or this course, I'd like
to direct your attention to a website from the
NHGRI. The National Human Genome Research Institute. That collects
all kinds of resources and information that you can
use to find out all the careers out there
that you can apply your new found genetic knowledge.